[Music]
you are entering a world of light no
more darkness no more [__] around
with [__] Momo's you've arrived
[__] the only thing is you are
the pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier do you hear me do you hear me
pilot to Bombardier do you hear me I see
some clouds I see some black people
jumping up and down I don't know where I
am
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about on a
Monday morning you bad [__] you
see what that breathing class does I got
smoked all the way in the bottom of my
[__] nutsack to reach my body that's
the beliefs on point [__] it's
a beautiful day to be alive uncle Joey
and a man of many rufus I got some
beautiful debt I got some beautiful more
debt I got some more debt where's the
Spanish people oh my god I love maracas
get the [__] a d-plus we got this
pocket mixture of heroin and mushrooms
[__] and [__] but hey enough with the
chitty-chat Oh Joey it's Monday we gotta
get this [__] party started Oh
beautiful
you got your clothes written plan you
got your dick wash you got your ass all
[__] bout it that's it now you need to
pick up a [__] envelope and your days
completely I'm saying you thank the Lord
to give you another day to sling dick
and who's better than you you know who
nobody you think people are better than
give it their own bunch of [__]
[__] Schmucks I mean here we are
seven the morning
burning The Tree of Life with the rest
of these [__] high-powered [__]
reefer head planet get the [__] out here
uncle Joey was powerful parenting you
[__] every modern like savages
that's how we do it contraceptives
understand me I'm with you your man
they're with us
I might have olivine I'm with you that's
all that [__] matters understand me
it's a beautiful [__] Monday you know
you got a full [__] day Eddie you got
a big dick [__] your personality he's
gotta go out there today and make it
yours I got a big day I thought you
didn't have a baby elephant elephants go
I got a meeting I got a podcast you know
and this is it this is what we do 50
[__] whatever [__] I don't even
know how old I am anymore the birth
certificate [__] saved on this ship
I'm just laying and think why with the
Sun tiles around but Joey spot that
[__]
you are entering a song that's right
the DA's are [__] this is where your
[__] you get on anybody else you
gonna show up with somebody else's words
that you heard some [__] dictionary
you go out there and sling they can
remember [__] and then over to
the fat lady sings and sometimes she's
breaking out of limbo right now warming
up
oh but that [__] is never gonna say
because I take it to the [__] hoop
ten out of ten times the same way you'll
pay [__] better whoo ten out of
[__] ten times why because you're a
[__] American Savage you don't give a
[__]
better imperative nation or red white
and blue means suck my dick I'm doing it
in my way like [__] Sinatra and you
don't like him [__] the time it's your
[__] world
the rest is up to you
the tacky flock of smoking this it's
Monday I gotta get you guys leaving the
house we [__] savages today
understand you don't leave the house or
a bow and arrow of fire
look at animals these are the Mao dica
lakh Mighty Clouds the [__] joy with
drop 92 Anna Monday morning
I switch it up a little bit in let's try
this little [__] sativa here
Skywalker
it's an Endicott the [__] am I thinking
let's do this [__] do this [__] what do
this [__] do this [__] what do this [__]
do this [__]
bet the pamphlet man [__] you I don't do
what you tell me [__] you I won't do
what you tell me that's it that's what
mondays are about [__] you I won't do
what you tell me I'm doing my way
understand
look at that little [__] cloudy
there's over the vapor man look at me
bum count uncle Joey's not allowed to
pipe the old-fashioned way with the
pumpkin pack both get sweating already
on a [__] Monday Morris smoking
reefer with you [__] you know
why because I love you [__] now I
didn't know it I know one of these
[__] butts you know you gotta [__]
that [__] [__] that [__] with together
to the end of wet desire Tommy seeking
them broke our field at Boone Boyet
Boone thickest layer that has a battle
not be taller become a pinnacle some
desire polka music and a romp up in the
higher your evil Santisima trabajamos a
pariah and that's it that's my big
moment for the middle oh you guys I'm
stoned already were [__] around with
death
there's no [__] mixture pirate but
together you this is like pro granny or
if some [__] the eye 6:22 powder I
had leftover I smokes in the 545 I just
sit down on the couch of my [__]
Mountain open not even drink the coffee
was called I just sat them
but I was [__] planning today
a man without a plan is not a man who's
ever gonna plan this [__]
you let us swim the other [__]
planned or something anyway I don't know
what to tell you people came out with
intention to get really [__] super
started
my goal was to [__] be stoned and
[__] it we get it
we hit the [__] this leftovers
galloping or exclusive I'm sorry
excalibur mystery we serve all these
[__] but look at these [__]
right here
this is [__] foolish
look at that put this in the car and let
it [__] dried a whole day about five
o'clock I'm gonna take our [__] car
this is gonna be dead this will be
smoked with a podcast that I understand
so we had them what your plan is for the
day we're gonna stab at the [__] neck
neck we're gonna kick it all right you
got do something today you gotta make
yourself [__] gone today you gotta do
something good you understand me and go
home
take out your decking door I did it
that's it that's all I got for you guys
to come let's have a start my day comes
and I have moves to make people sing
I guess tonight 8 p.m. Pacific Standard
Time that means 11:00 on the East Coast
10 o'clock give you little [__]
Nashville me understand I'm happy I hope
you're happy I hope you world is [__]
beautiful today your family as well and
I hope you get out there and be the best
you to be today [__] all this nonsense
like I said you got to be a bad
[__]
gotta be dangerous you understand me you
gotta be so dangerous people even wanna
hang out with you [__] these
dangerous you know stab people whatever
you [__] does when you want them when
they feel your [__] energy they know
this [__] you [__] around and
with that I love you guys yeah 8:00 p.m.
tonight be there or be square and the
Stanley I get up for work you're
watching on Vimeo tomorrow
I mean Saturday night I'm opening up for
Andrew Dice Clay and my [__] goal
bothered I'd have made me even gone
stayed the first time since it'll be
another
next we come to Sacramento on the
weekend for that [__] [__] bird what
what what all right I love you
[__] have a great day
[__] stay black and beautiful as you
[__] already you don't need me
to tell you that get that moment I'll be
down